thank you yasser yes i'm here with the
world's number two fabiano caruana
after a very difficult game fabiano
you're one of the experts in this
variation i remember the last
the first time i saw you play this was
with white pieces in 2016
uh against onyx then you played it with
the black pieces then again with the
white pieces you're one of the experts
in this
variation take us through the nuances of
it
fine this was just a ridiculous game i
mean what can i say about it uh
the thing is i played this line before
and wrap it against
lanier um
i mean i of course he knew this and he
was he was ready for this line
uh it's it's a very dangerous line for
black
also for white of course because white's
king is extremely weak
but black is basically making only moves
to not lose like this was always
considered
much better for white until recently
when
it was discovered that this is actually
playable
um due to uh the evolving of the new
computers or
yeah i don't think this is not really
let's say
this analysis can't be found i don't
think over
just by let's say the human mind you
have to
to involve some uh some computers and
and yeah here he just mixed up i mean
like when he played f4 i wasn't entirely
sure
if maybe there was some prep something
that i missed because he has his rook g3
f5 which is
um i guess possible but i had a
slight feeling that he wanted to go for
this line which is roof g5 queen h6
f4 knight f4 and he just inverted the
move order by playing f4 first
and a forward g5 um and now i can
transpose a queen h6 so there's no point
system of order for him
so this being the main line more or less
of the variation
well if i play queen h6 yeah this is one
of one of the very critical lines
um so i didn't i mean i
i realized that this is a strange move
order
and i figured it was probably just a
human error i i didn't think that this
was some sort of alternative move order
so
uh f5 was easy to play and it it was
clear that white is in great danger here
um maybe borderline losing and i thought
d4 is the most natural move
and here okay i burned a lot of time
um it was like this is his trick you
know that
after rookie three he has bishop c4
otherwise he just resigns
um but bishop c4 wins so this was the
small trick
the point of d4 um
but anyway it looked like this position
is very very close to winning to for me
and my yeah my first idea was h5 but
then i didn't
it also weakens my king a lot like it it
puts this queen in a
vulnerable place because i'm not h3 and
potentially but
um but there's no clear follow-up and
then yeah this was
my other idea but i failed to realize
how strong it was
and then when i played 93 i started to
wonder like yeah and
h5 is very important because now queen
g392 comes and
queen f1 uh so i he would probably have
to play my d2
i think this is what he was actually
mentioning as well but then at least i
can play knight d3
and this is i'm definitely better in the
game
and now i see that knight d5 doesn't
move um of course it's it's very
difficult to like
this is also what he missed he did not
yeah this move i
with this tactic i i also didn't see but
at the very least i think knight d3 is
um
well it's much better for black um
and it was also like i was even thinking
he could try knight d2 here
and then i was thinking of like we have
six so it was kind of um because knight
c 194
is well it's a bit of a mess yeah
um and i just like i thought this was a
very good
move i just missed bishop f4 so i i
thought he would
he would not be able to take basically i
thought he would have to play knight d2
or bishop d2 or maybe some other move
like rookie four knight f2 queen g2 but
i didn't really believe in this for him
it's like not immediately obvious how i
win but
like he can't really free himself yeah
although i
it wasn't clear to me over the board how
how how much better i am
um but yeah then when i play 93 i
realize he just has bishop f4
um i'm honestly kind of lucky
that i have queen h6 because otherwise i
guess it's still a drill but
it could be dangerous if he consolidates
and um
and the bishop on e5 is just
tremendously strong and area was a draw
with i think
like basically any movements leading to
troll like queen g queen g3 is a draw
um but bishop iv is just finishing the
game
obviously a draw with the black pieces
is never a bad result
nevertheless you did have some chances
and that must be a bit disappointing
what are your immediate feelings after
this game
um yeah disappointed because
it was uh it was a chance basically
to win with black uh an unexpected
chance i don't think
um i mean sort of an accident because
um it was just an opening hiccup from
from his side of it
uh normally these things don't happen of
course it's
sometimes it's very difficult to um to
actually
like in this line sometimes it's losing
by force but you have to find only moves
it's very common
um but yeah knight d3 missing bishop 4
was
really kind of gross how do you feel
about this theoretical duels you
uh very often engage with maximum are
you happy with that
well it's i think it's natural for us
because we're both pretty principled
players especially him
uh he really sticks to his openings um
he's i think he actually enjoys
um for example playing the greenville
night or pretty much exclusively
and trying to defend those openings and
and with white he just plays the most
direct lines almost always so
so you usually get a theoretical battle
with maxime um
especially if you're like not trying to
avoid the main lines with black then you
usually get it
actually would have been it would have
been funny if he had
played the right move order because i'm
curious what he what he wanted because
for example there's this like
absolutely amazing position
um where yeah i don't think you see this
material balance often
uh white has a bishop and a queen for
two rooks
but the king is in actually extreme
danger um
and sometimes the king ends up on like
seat white's king ends up on c5 or d5 or
or b5 so
it would have been fun to see what uh
what would have happened if it is
let's say taking a more normal route
normal uh
is a big word in this position fabi
thank you very much for joining us and
see you
in the next few days thank you guys back
to you thank